nachdem ich bereits den ersten und
zweiten teil des impossible crysis auf
einem kanal gespielt habe konnte nun der
dritte teil
ja ich werde auch hier wieder gnadenlos
verpacken das stimmt teilte jetzt eine
posse begrüßen ich kennen sollte das ist
ein quiz auf eine website bei der man
fragen gestellt bekommt man hat fünf
leben und das quiz ist eigentlich
unmöglich zu schaffen und besonders für
mich du [ __ ] ist es unmöglich von
daher habe ich mir hier eine brille
aufgesetzt
wenn ich das schlauer macht allerdings
würde ich sagen wir fangen ja direkt an
mit dem quiz also wir klicken auf play
chris m das ist jetzt der dritte teil
wir haben chapter ronchamp der tour und
chapter wie comingsoon ach du kacke das
heißt ich kann noch mehr videos hier zu
machen wir machen in diesem video
einfach capture one im das intro
überspringen wir mal und die erste frage
ist how do you start in impossible quiz
also einerseits carefully confidential i
like this oder paypal ii
es könnte wieder alles richtig sein ich
würde sagen ich starte das quiz
vorsichtig geschafft zweite frage
wirtschafte following ist das shooting
star also was davon ist ja eine person
die gerade so durch die decke geht ein
angehender superstar major heuser meiner
sita ob youtube oder clint eastwood ich
sagte gysi dem actually smart watch my
dance statement ist die drin
wo es euch wissen wir nun als termin als
hätte nach zwölf halb 37 minuten von
drei oder hammer
ich bin 32 ja mein gott das eine fliege
in meiner lampe ist eine fliege in der
lampe bruder komm raus hier
das ist das der falsche ausgang ist hier
oben raus seht ihr sie und ist schon
draussen bilder fliegt sie noch um
komfort oder du musst einfach nur hier
nach oben fliegen
da kommt noch ein bisschen weiter bis
ihr weiter nach oben bisschen komme ich
vielleicht doch noch retten 2000 jahre
später das heutige video ist keine
fliegen rettungsaktion von daher machen
wir weiter mit unserem quiz motto you
call of female im uhr
ist leben und hier york lemuren sind auf
jeden fall das ist auch so wie diese
dieses aus madagaskar dieses tier also
wie nennt man einen weiblichen leben
hohe miss magic wolbeck oder sv maur
youtube ließ point kies trotz also in
den osten zeigen norden süden westen
osten das stimmt auf jeden fall alles
also ich wusste dass es falsch ist wenn
ich auf osten clique aber
[Musik]
was ist es denn dann ich klicke auf den
westen das ist falsch auf 9
was war da
raleigh
oh mein gott
man muss auf dieses kleine ding
draufklicken weil das ding auch nach
osten zeitalter das noch nicht wahr
what is the best friends oder kenzo
diese fragen machen wirklich überhaupt
gar keinen sinn das ist gar keine frage
fällt mir gerade auf ersten beiden teile
des impossible chris das haben wir heute
gezeigt dass man auch solche
kleinigkeiten achten sollten daher kein
fragezeichen ist würde ich einfach auf
was drauf klicken
oh mein gott ich weiß nicht
in ligen gegen kranke adler auf
sonnenschein so muss man erst mal kommen
lebensretter auf die lvm a b c d e f g
ich wusste dass es falsch ist aber ich
wollte trotzdem drauf klicken
ok ich dachte gerade weil elfe bett und
dass es hier der siebte buchstabe
aber hakan ich auch nicht auswählen wie
ihr bett aber auch hier ist es das haar
kann ich denn
frage nummer neuen which of the
following speedcore elxleben big blind
pickel blend peak oder blitz ging das
ist ein blindes schwein also sage ich
blind ich wusste dass das falsch war man
muss jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder denken
hey okay die augen sind kaputt
von daher würde ich sagen ist das hier
richtig ist und natürlich ist das wieder
was
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
ich muss ich musste spanien zählen ihr
könnt ja gerne in den kommentaren wieder
mit raten um so wie ihr das bei den
letzten teilen ja auch gemacht habe ich
habe ich euch übrigens auch in der
beschreibung unten verlinkt also falls
ihr luca macht und posten quiz teil 1
und teil 2 sehen wollt sind die und in
der beschreibung das ist halt schon 13
jahre her romani letters in assassins 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 normalerweise wird man
sagen 9
aber irgendwas how many letters
ich sage an
neun der safe nicht richtig gewesen
achtung spiegels zurück ich muss ja
gerade wieder zu der frage hin kommen
bei der ich gerade mal noch fliegt diese
fette fliege ich mein gebt euch mal wie
fertig ist das metzinger daneben geht
mir hier was ist denn mit dieser fiege
los du deine mission lebt die davor der
theorie für die unterbrechung in die
ganze zeit aber diese fliege bereitet
mir hier ich kopfschmerzen mit schürze
dahinten am vorhang
aber naja wir sind ja bei dieser frage
stehen geblieben ich würde jetzt
tatsächlich sagen das ist 4 ist weil es
heißt ja nicht also ist er nicht die
anzahl der buchstaben sondern die
buchstaben sind also 4
ja und nein ich habe nur 20 sekunden ich
habe keine ahnung was ich hier machen
soll wahrscheinlich die ganzen sachen
hier verbinden 56 77 89 und die nummer
what do feed for breakfast cornflakes
croissants oder bacon
was essen kannst du dich mal verblüffen
was essen füße zum frühstück
diese frage beschreibt eigentlich das
komplette willst also wer am einerseits
trost da muss man nicht noch nichts
davon wirklich sinn
ich meine mit dem ist gene menem ist es
rappelt in der kiste ene mene meck und
du bist weg
das war richtig oder vielleicht auch
alles richtig ganz kurze zwischen
anmerkungen und zwar ist ja gerade wenn
das video rauskommt der 21 jahren war
das heißt in einem monat am 21 februar
habe ich geburtstag und in dem zuge
haben uns gedacht dass wir einen rudi
launischen werden im luca shop und zwar
diesen look to you die der wird an
meinem geburtstag am 21 februar 1000 mal
in den luca shop kommen und zu jeder
bestellung falls sie einen kriegen
sollte bekommt ihr einen schwarzen
smileys ticker von mir höchst persönlich
signiert also 21 02 im kalender
eintragen
das hier ist wieder was auf zeit
da steht vor und man muss sie vor okay
ich habe nur noch zwei leben des quiz
make you feel also einerseits glücklich
das auf keinen fall
traurig würde ich sagen auch nicht ich
würde sagen böse das hat erstmalig für
bösel zum glück komme ich noch aus
dieser icq zeit und schülervz wo man nur
solche smiley hatte landis quests
ach das ist der das erkennt man immer
direkt wir sind jetzt drei wochen später
hätte ich google jetzt mein gott ist
nicht deren ernst klappt das jetzt
musste p drücken auf der tastatur weil
sie heißt wie soll man auf so was kommt
wer keine feinde meaning of life also wo
findet man die bedeutung des lebens in
der bibel im wörterbuch in dem
telefonbuch oder in der zeitung ist hier
wieder irgendwas sagen
ganz blöd überlegt es geht darum welche
feinde meaning of life also die
bedeutung des wortes leben und das
findet man im wahlkreis okay dies war
ich habe echt aus den bisherigen teilen
gelernt winne feierte petzschner im
match in westport hin aber okay das weiß
auch aus dem ersten chris das dorthin
richtig ist wenn ganz vorsichtig jetzt
hier mit dem klicken weil es irgendwann
sein kann dass wenn man das zu schnell
geklickt hat das dann okay er trug
statt neun sekunden was 21 durch 10 sind
sind 2,1 das steht ihr nicht
hey was soll daran falsch gewählt herr
ich habe jetzt mal nachgeschaut mann
soll irgendeinen punkt ziehen bei der
question number hier genau und hier
zwischen genau da wo mein gott alter das
war eine heidenarbeit gerade ich wusste
20 fragen durchgehend wieder diese kag
spermien zählen und so weiter und so
fort und dann ebenso einen punkt
umziehen
wie soll man das schaffen ohne die
antwort zu sonderfrage zu googeln motto
you cry baby joghurt
dk
die und jetzt wieder auf zeit 123 weiter
oh mein gott ich hab's geschafft
oh mein gott ich schwitze wie scheiße
which smerling gussverfahren
das war für das video mit der maus
darüber also warum ist der sand nass
wegen meeres gras kraft weil es regnet
oder weiß ja facebook
[Musik]
natürlich auch falls sie retweetet
keystone presse
ich war vorhin auch schon richtig heiß
that even posten bleiben das ziel ist es
durch yus messer of water herbie hancock
point of god what the [ __ ] ist seit dem
schuljahr downhill ich nehme das wieder
mein gott es war richtig nein nein was
mache ich hier jetzt doch
nach rom zusammen
[Musik]